so with 10 panelist and you know half
hour I don't think there's a there's a
ton of time that we have to to you know
rile up the speakers and see what we can
you know get out of the various levels
of description that we heard of but I
think there's also very little doubt now
that the the range of ways in which we
refer to internal models is pretty wide
going from you know the single cell
levels in cerebellum like structures
right at the very one end too it's
interesting it seems like almost people
group themselves according to the no not
quite there's a little bit of a mix-up
it's not going from more molecular tool
hola cognitive but at the other end is
you know being a really probabilistic
model so the I'm hoping that all of you
will participate and sort of ask
questions but all started with with sort
of a simple question which is with the
variety of descriptions that were given
maybe each of you can give three four
minute synthesis of what you think
actually is common among the the things
that you study versus the other end
especially the people who study neural
circuit motifs do you think there is
anything you study that actually bears
on the types of probabilistic models
that for example then and josh talked
about for a higher level cognition and
vice versa for people who study you know
more cognitive levels where do you see a
connection between the neural circuit
motifs can you can you imagine that
there is actually a linkage to describe
what you study based on those neural
structures
okay right so i talked about negative
images in this fish and there's a lot of
parallels between negative images and
efficient you know motor adaptation
paradigms and cerebellar dependent motor
adaptation so you the fish is learning
something he's put off target he had the
neurons adapt and then you turn the
stimulus off and you see a negative
image that's like reaching to a target
your perturbed you hit the target then
there's after effects I understand that
in our my system by adjusting synaptic
weights I got some representations and
granule cells I've got some weights I've
got a supervised signal from the world
that is a sensory prediction error
that's what I understand I but I'm very
interested in understanding how you know
how to link that to bayesian idea is
just to take one example so I would be
that's the kind of thing I'm interested
in how do I go from the internal model
that I understand at the level of cells
and circuits in this and we could talk
more generally about the cerebellum to
where we kind of all of us in the
cerebellum are influenced by these mar
albus models that are traditional models
that have a lot of synaptic weights in
plasticity where is the you know I what
I'm interested in is in the connection
between those domains and and some of
these these higher level ideas and I
don't know where I'm very interested to
know and hear what the other speakers
think about how to bridge some of these
gaps and what are some of the
experiments we could do or what are some
of the mechanisms that we think could
help to bridge those gaps is it the
mechanisms look the same as the ones we
know is it is it some of the same things
but deeper and more is it you know if
you have a bunch of these internal
models based on synaptic plasticity and
some micro zones of the cerebellum and
you wire them all up together could you
get some of these hierarchies or some of
these other ideas coming out of them or
do we need entirely new mechanisms what
should we be looking for in the brain i
guess is one of the things I'm
interested in in our fish work i think
generalization is a critical issue and
that i think you know kind of bears on
some of these issues whether what is
fish is learning is just a giant look up
or how well can generalize to new
contacts that seems like a critical
question about learning and the power of
these systems i talked about granule
cells one of the things you wonder is
you know when you start to run out of
grain
that would be a big criticism of these
traditional mar albus models as you're
basically learning some giant lookup
table and wind is that what do you do
when that runs out so what are the some
solutions to these problems I think are
interesting questions so I have no
answers but but I'm very think it's it's
a it's good to have a conversation about
these kind of things and the cerebellum
is you know involved in internal models
we know a huge amount about the
circuitry of it and yet there's a giant
gaping chasm between you know what
people are doing at the circuit level in
the cerebellum and any of these
interesting ideas so it's kind of I
think it's an important pressing issue
to think about how you might bridge
those gaps because if we can't do it
there I don't know where we're going to
be able to do it so I can I can do this
right around so your model seems very
nice in that you're in the middle your
study is very nice in that it seems like
what Daniel talked about about
structural learning what I talked about
and about the assumptions that are kind
of ingrained in the internal model seem
seem like ingrained in your in the
granular in the basis set you found in a
gram yourselves and and the distribution
of that basis it because that's going to
dictate how learning generalizes how you
make sense of some ambiguous error
signals and how these are projected into
it so now be interesting to think about
wood the wood the fish be able to learn
a new structure in a way right would it
be able to somehow modify its basis said
and then learn more arbitrary things
that might not encounter in nature but
might you know once you expose a long
enough in the in the laboratory that it
actually could acquire this structure or
ask otherwise how does this structure
come about in the grandeur survey as it
is it genetically inborn or is it
something that that just reflects the
learned learn structural the loan prior
from that it experience in the
environment
so I'm gonna go home and put some yellow
and red blocks on my split Bell
treadmill and we'll see if you can make
predictions about what happens oh no
seriously I think that one of the big
certainly from my point of view one of
the big problems that I have is when you
use devices or robots to try to train
human behavior the problem of
generalization is huge if you want it to
generalize and turning off and on
generalization is something that we'd
like to be able to do in a better way
and so you know when when can you pull
something into a certain structure and
when can you not can you take it out so
I think that that's an area that is very
useful to me now the other thing that I
would say is in patient groups we have
patients that have different kinds of
diseases that affect different cell
types and we don't understand at all how
those patients are different they can
look a little bit different but we don't
understand in terms of their learning
ability and their control their ability
to control movement what what we would
expect to see so on my end I mean I'm
Way out on the on the disease end so I
think that these are some of the
interesting questions that I would have
after this ah blocks no not two blocks I
actually going to go for history so I
think it was really interesting watching
all the speakers at this meeting and
going from the very reductionist to the
higher-level topics it's actually kind
of a an old thing so fit 65 years ago in
1952 two seminal papers are published by
Roger Sperry and by Van hoschton middle
shet talking about corollary discharge
any friends copy respectively in 15
years after that Hans Lucas Tiber
founded the brain and cognitive sciences
department which was psychology but it
turned into BCS and I wasn't around back
then that was before my time ten years
later I was born and but from what I
understand back then there was a lot of
talk about this so corollary discharged
from the reductionist level up through
honzik estoy bieber talking about it at
the psychiatric level and talking about
you know lesion studies in human
and the deficits that would occur and
how this could be related to Roger
sperrys ideas and von hoschton middle
set saw ideas but at the time there
wasn't any neural evidence for any of
this so Roger Sperry and run halsted
mittelstadt did really interesting
behavioral manipulations turning eyes
around and reversing crossing pathways
and things like that where they could
infer a lot and nowadays we have the
neural data and in the humans in humans
we have imaging data and we have a
really beautiful againt psychological
experiments and I'd like to see kind of
a renaissance of that integration of the
two levels and I think meetings like
this I think that we're kind of getting
there I know in my own experiments we've
been looking at our perceptive stability
of the visual scene across eye movements
and we've been looking at it in human
subjects recently doing psychophysics
and asking questions about priors so for
example if we make an eye movement and
we whether or not we noticed something
moves across that I'm event I think has
a lot to do with our expectation of
should it move or not so if we see a
rock move that would be a lot more
surprising than if we see an insect move
for example same basic image projected
onto the retina but our priors will
influence our sensitivity to that
movement and we have preliminary
psychophysics data suggesting that this
is actually true and to be really
interesting to kind of to see into study
that at the neural level and to
coordinate with people doing
psychological experiments with priors
and like Josh was talking about in the
last experiment with kind of physics
models of the world to kind of bring it
all together and understand how the
brain does that at the neural level and
at the psychological level yeah so I
guess for me it's been a very
interesting day I came from more of a
sensory coding sensorimotor
transformation background so I kind of
came in to decide this area of internal
models and as I said initially
accidentally and I think it's a made
very clear to me that when you think
about sensory processing or sensory
motor transformations it's sort of it
implies some sort of linearity which
doesn't really exist because if you
think about
sensory processing typically we're
sensing you know the stimuli we sense
around us to do things right so you're
really sensing for action and I think
this is something that you know students
don't really appreciate until you you
know they get towards the end of their
neuroscience because it's something
that's evolved later and in the way we
even teach neuroscience we really focus
on this sort of linear representation of
sensory processing and decisions and
then motor output but it's really a it's
a loop and so I think that's one thing
that I've really learned to appreciate
and in order to understand that you have
to have internal models and I've began
based on the background the vestibular
system focused on this simple
sensorimotor transformation which is
either vestibulo-ocular reflex or
vestibular spinal reflexes but i think
what help and I guess I could say one
thing and listening to Nate's beautiful
work I'm always very frustrated that I
can't get to that level in the monkey
and I think about how I can do that and
I talked to Nate and I get kind of
frustrated but it's okay but I guess you
know in terms of higher level perceptual
things that were discussed today you
know you could take a simple system like
the vestibular system and we're actually
starting to record in thalamus and we
see actually the same things and that's
not surprising we know we see reoffer
and suppression my guess if we did one
of these training paradigms we'd see
that as well so this opens the question
of how distributed is the the
suppression or the internal models that
we're looking at and we all assume very
often they're occurring in the
cerebellum and there's evidence that
suggests that some parts of them are you
know but then we see that it's more
complex right and I think that's
something that I don't have a good
handle on of you know I mean there are
some types of internal models that are
probably in the cerebellum but it's you
know what is an internal model and you
know are so I I mean these are these are
things that are open questions so I mean
and sort of the the fact that we see the
reactor and suppression at the level
that i miss you know it's similar to
what people are now seeing in visual
cortex and auditory cortex so it's a
very general principle which i think in
the lily in the last several years that
we appreciate how fundamental action is
to the way we process so i think it's
actually a really exciting time and that
so I guess I'd like to just contraste
thiis and nate's to Josh and mine so I
mean I think we think of prob listing
models and the reason we think of them
as prob listing models but I think you
don't think of them as probabilistic
maybe is that it's really important that
we need to have an answer but have
knowledge about the certainty no answer
and that's because you know often you
want to take that answer and compared
with another answer and you know how not
just what the answer is but how reliable
is I'll come at it with a cost and so
we're very interested I guess in not
only the answer I'm not sure in the
blocks toss if you said people is going
to fall over not how confident are you
about that people give you very accurate
answers on really how reliable their
arms and we find that now tasks so do
you to know whether you think you things
like you think it's a determinist thing
you just get an answer but not that you
represent your certainty in the answer
do you think your serger to also know
how certain they are about the object
out because not to decide what to do
about it and that the certainty really
plays an important role or if you want
to then take the head Singh will compile
it with vision or something you need to
know how certainly signals are do you
see those things and you think you're
doing this publicity computation going
on really in that sense and I said let's
get backwards now the higher stage that
needs to take that into account okay so
it's going to make a decision so the
variable the variable thing you're
firing and there's nothing there there's
no signal than that or something which
passes on to say you know I think that
something up there but i'm not sure
compared to i'm actually certain from
the signal there's that seems that since
I mean that's to do that then that's an
impoverished version of the beige
inversion extent I guess yeah I don't
know I don't know I mean in any systems
including in our system even at the
first stage you get feedback from the
highest stages after a few synapses so
you certainly couldn't rule out that
those synapses are coming back that
information is coming back and we
haven't explicitly look for it so it
could be I mean is one of the things we
see in motor behavior right is there's
variability and I mean one of the things
we'd like to do the question we have is
if you start to apply perturbations just
kind of keep you in the noise ban or
poke you out what's the tolerance oh my
i don't know if that gets at your
question but there probably is some
level of tolerance
I mean I don't know how much precision
we can get to to answer your question
right because there was you know every
time you see a little bit of difference
but my guess is they'll be some
nonlinear point some point where
suddenly you're in a different regime
right so several people during the
course of the day have admitted that
they were in domains that were beyond
their comfort zone and I think that is
important in trying to answer meh dad's
question or any question in neural
science at the moment that you find
yourself in a region where you feel
inadequate and stretched and so as a
circuit empiricist the reason I'm
sitting next of their guy on the left to
me is not an accident there because my
role in life for however long is
scientifically to provide circuit
explanations for the generic synthesis
that Daniel and people like Daniel
provide where they pose questions from
engineering biomechanical perspective
that need understanding in a different
currency the currency of neurons and
circuits and behavioural output
functions and how long will it take to
achieve that merger I don't know you
know some some things I think in the
course of a decade well and when I
listen to Josh right I'm a little more
pessimistic about coming up with
causality explanations of what you're
describing or Rebecca or summer because
these are very different things that are
the you know the topic of the next 50 60
hundred years to try and provide but you
have you have to start somewhere and you
have to start with the fact that their
86 billion neurons in the human brain
and it's not an accident the way they're
connected
and you know that is what makes this to
me an exciting endeavor to try and you
know then there are the you know the
enthusiasts and how far that leap of you
know interpolation is going to be I
think is a an individual topic for you
know some people don't I remember when
rod McKinnon was at a meeting and he
announced a dramatic change in his
research program on potassium channels
to move from you know one subunit and
gating to something that was on the same
potassium channels you know five
angstroms away in the intracellular
domain was ever robbed that was the leap
of a lifetime for us you know it's
somewhat less and so I think what we've
heard today is a you know meh dad was
very clever choosing this topic because
as many people have committed it means
different things to different people and
gives you the substrate for different
I'm at one end of that continuum and I
want to get to the other end and I know
I won't and that's a you know we don't
even know how many nerve cells there are
different classes and nerve cells in the
spinal cord and you know the stuff that
we have been doing suggests that they're
200 different classes of interneurons
that are controlling motor output so
that is true you realize immediately
that the whole thing is hopeless and you
have a lot to do and you're never going
to be out of a job
you're not you're cited like me Tom
that's a problem but the 30,000 foot
view I mean I'm quite heartened by
seeing parallels between the mailing and
bird systems I mean it's really just a
going to speak specifically about our
own work but to peer into promoter
networks and see an architecture that
connects to the auditory system I think
that was surprising to me but the
generative aspects this is something
this is a approach that pretty much one
cell at a time but generative aspects
and birdsong are really an important
part of learning and that's something
i'm i'm curious about both in terms of
statistics but also in terms of how much
those individual and generative
processes interact with the model a
beautiful aspect of birdsong as you can
implant at least one part of the model
in the bird's brain by just playing it a
sound but it seems like it has an
ability to generate its own and profit
or e behavior on top of that that
ultimately lends itself an individual
song even though it's very similar to
the one it copies it allows it to be a
little bit different and so there's a
hint of individuation and
self-determination in that process that
i think is quite quite profound I'll
leave it at that so my general feeling
about trying to link up the two extremes
is that in terms of looking at neurons
and trying to understand circuit
mechanisms we need to come up with some
sort of you know underlying principle
that can explain all the individual
components that we're seeing right and
so you know the analogy that I have my
head is like you have you know a video
of a bouncing ball right you can monitor
every pixel in that video right and try
to understand what is going on in that
video and you can do that and it's
likely to be sort of an inefficient
representation but if you could somehow
figure out that there's Newton law
Newton's laws going on right then you
have a really concise summary of many
individual components all of which are
changing over time
and so if we can come up with something
like that right from at the circuit
level right then that might be the link
point to these higher level concepts
that Daniel in and Josh are talking
about so sort of looking at the work
that I presented this morning I think it
this is sort of in the middle of the two
ends of the spectrum and so I'm going to
try to relate to each of the two
extremes so I think the relationship
between that the work that I presented
and sort of the higher level sort of
Bayesian view of things is that we
really view this internal model that
we're extracting as a subjects prior
assumptions about the world right and so
where we're going with this is to try to
use these concepts to understand
learning right and then trying to link
to sort of lower level circuit
mechanisms I think it would be really
interesting to address these
shortcomings that I mentioned in my talk
which is that we're not actually
recording the corollary discharge or
from the neurons that are actually
implementing these internal models and
you know if one day we could do that
then trying to incorporate that into
this internal model formulation and you
know trying to figure out what is the
structure of the internal model that can
best explain what we're seeing in the
neural activity in in these experiments
I'm not sure where to begin except to
say just um the idea of 50 to 60 years
to bridge cognition and neural circuits
again I would call that optimism and not
pessimism and I think that's exciting I
think me know that I might even still be
alive then oh it's when you when you
read you know Craig from 1945 it sounds
like an impossible gap right or when you
look at a lot of cognitive psychology
and it you know it's it I don't you
don't even know where to begin to
understand how all the 86 billion
neurons are the 200 types just in one
small part of the nervous system relate
to the cognitive level but I guess part
of why I'm excited about this the whole
spectrum of what you have here and again
compliments Tamara Dodd for putting
together a really interesting group
that's that it raises these challenges
but actually I think offers hope and
optimus
is you know that they're there or there
are some aspects of human cognition that
are really the core part of the matter
their present in young infants even if
their ways in which even a 12 month old
is smarter than any machine system a
robot that's ever been built so it's
really about what makes us smart and yet
it's these things that you know do
relate just to what Byron was saying
it's you know basically some kind of
computational approximation to Newton's
laws on objects that can make sense of
this common-sense physics that the
infant is somehow internalized right and
you know I again I'm optimistic not only
in the connections that people here but
the work I showed briefly at the end
Jason Fisher's work in Nancy cameras lab
right that the the the different kinds
of tasks were studying there seemed to
be parts of the brain that are
specialized for doing this cut these
kind of computations it's very
preliminary so you know we'll see how
that plays out but let's say they're
right right again I'm this is way out of
my comfort zone but I don't think it's
in it's an interesting maybe suspicious
coincidence that one of the two main
places that they are finding a selective
physics signal is in the premotor area
right the idea that there's a coupling
between the internal models in the motor
system that we use for planning our
actions that is that we're the topic of
most of what those other speakers were
talking about and that you can study in
all sorts of ways in neural systems and
all sorts of different species and that
that you know that there might be a
direct link between those circuits and
the ones that are at the heart of human
common-sense cognition about the world
that's very exciting and I don't know
what the other speakers think of that
idea if there's if that's there might be
anything there between you know maybe
another way to put it is Mara Dodd
titled the symposium internal models in
sensory motor and cognitive function and
I think most people were talking about
sensory motor function as a cognitive
scientist it seems to me and you know
Daniel and I were maybe two of the
people who were talking about cognition
but if we look at the part of cognition
that that it might share something
functionally computationally with the
sensory motor systems which have these
internal models which you can study and
all sorts of very powerful neural
circuit ways then maybe there maybe
there's a neural circuit commonality to
that might have some hope of and you
know answering the kind of mom is
looking for
I just maybe we should open up also to
the to the audience I was trying to
think myself whether there was some sort
of qualitative divided between the
sensory motor and the cognitive and what
would that divide be and I don't think
it well I may just say that everyone
everyone here was talking about learning
models based on learning and and there
either was or certainly could be a
probabilistic aspect to all of those
learning models I don't think that was
it whether animals have access to
knowledge of their probabilities I'm not
quite sure but but at least in terms of
the mechanisms are just probabilistic
learning mechanism leading to something
you could call a model it would seem to
me that maybe a qualitative difference
are the the difference between models
that are strictly feed-forward based on
learned priors about sensory input and
and then expected outcomes and the
models that require actual simulations
sort of what you are talking about like
the premotor so it's one thing to build
even like a face generative face model
which is very complex but actually the
way you talked about it could be done
without all kinds of iteration and
recursion and so on just strictly
feed-forward straight through the kinds
of things that neuroscientists you know
sort of know how to study but then when
you imagine like well what is it like to
imagine shaking the table and simulating
the blocks falling off which is half the
audience you know solve the problem that
way that is not that's that's involving
all kinds of iteration recursion and so
on and so on that to me seems
qualitatively different when you get
into those kinds of physics models what
happens if I get in my car and I get
into traffic and how am I going to get
to work that kind of planning in that
maybe that maybe the step that's beyond
what US neuroscientists normally can
make progress with
so I want to be able to evolve to
mistake there so so I think I think a
promoter arias is a really interesting
zone to be in because mmm for example
from Richards talk we saw that in the in
the equivalent and promote equivalent in
songbird it seemed to be quite you know
a high level temporal representation of
motor behavior that is being extracted
in hpc we see in our work that we teach
people a range of different fine motor
skills and premotor cortex looks like it
extracts some regularity out of this
pool of motor skills that it needs to
learn and kind of lift it to a more
abstract level that I can then flexibly
recombine so seem to be something about
the circuit of premotor cortex that is
really good at not just learning by rote
learning or repetition but somehow
discover somehow in the neural network
those regularities and then utilize them
and new in new situations is of course
much more modest than what talked about
but you could see how how those circuits
might you know something about this
circus might be then extrapolated to do
solve something that is more akin to
cognition so so I think there's some
some interesting links here that I think
might be valuable to follow follow
through can I just quickly just follow
up on also just one thing in answering
Bob's questions so yeah I guess um I
think that's you you're exactly right
that's a very interesting distinction
but i think it's not just human
cognition that has that ability to do
some kinds of mental simulation right i
mean i think one like I came from very
interesting conference last week the
fens brain conference in Denmark and
there were a bunch of people for example
Lauren Frank another great alum of our
program studying you know various kinds
of these you know hippocampal ripples he
came out of Matt Wilson's lab and again
locally we've seen this from add another
people working there so that's there you
know there are places where some kind of
forward simulation planning algorithms
that you can study in rodents you know
might plausibly be doing something
similar you know Howard eichenbaum had
similar ideas in epic you know other
other kinds of not just spatial aspects
of
campbell function so i know i think it's
i think you're exactly right to look at
that and i think they're going to be
very different kinds of neural processes
that will do these different kinds of
inference in internal models it's just
it's not only humans that do the
interesting kinds of planning I just
wanted to ask the panel if you know what
is the opinion of you in terms of
connecting the two apart you know the
two extremes of the spectrum meaning
psychophysics and measuring behavior by
humans of relevant tasks on one hand and
then the other end which is poking
electrodes and looking into behavior of
neurons or even in a neuroimaging so how
how should we bridge the two x needed to
say opposites
well in my view this is the the basic
problem doesn't matter whether one is
you you want to extend as I mentioned
before and I think that in the motor
control system the insights that have
emerged from human mode of physiology
serve as an example of what should be
driving experimentation at this neuron
physiology circuit level and you see
many many examples of that in this
vestibular system world or this world of
you know different strategies of motor
activation what you can do in humans you
know albeit slightly you know
associative is amazing actually and many
many models have emerged from human
physiology that I think are not being
paid sufficient attention to from the
animal experimental group partly because
these worlds don't collide often enough
so to me you know the whole purpose of
being in neural science is to extend
yourself beyond something that you think
about a lot and take a big leap and see
what you can do to bridge that distant
gap and how distant as I was saying you
know is the subject of individual choice
we motor to for example face recognition
language
not easily at the moment but the things
that Daniel was talking about in the way
in which decision evaluation has an
impact on some sensory world is telling
you that they're things that you need to
understand that we don't understand at
the moment and there are a lot of those
things but um you could say that any two
of the talks that you've heard today
there are points of contact which could
be driven for it so mark talking about
you know colliculus into frontal eye
field is a set of problems that could be
analyzed you know there's very little
work just to sort of bring it down to
earth on colliculus function using
modern molecular genetic approaches but
there are people in language you're
beginning to try and look at that so I
think the optimistic thing is that
nothing is beyond the range of pursuit
at the moment it's just that there are a
lot of things that you could turn your
attention to I think also I'd like to
emphasize the the Worth and importance
of basic research and pretty much
everybody on this panel does basic
research we're studying the problems we
don't know what the answer is going to
be there's not a definitive disease that
we're trying to you know cure Amy's
probably the one exception here is
actually trying to help people we're
trying to help people but in a more
abstract way I think there are a lot of
animal models that can be appropriately
propria Talis a lot of insight into
human behavior with the right
preparations that are used the right
behavioral tasks that are used Rich's
work in birdsong for example looking at
the neural circuits looking at all the
way from the neurotransmitter level with
a lot of anatomy but getting into
vocalization and learning and
communication between conspecifics that
has direct analogues to I think human
behavior in a lot of ways a lot of base
creatures research has been done on
invertebrates which aren't really
represented here beautiful coral air
discharge work in crickets and other
invertebrates and insects but that has
really informed our my work in primates
and I think of the work in humans as
well so it's a beautiful spectrum I
think across the animal kingdom that we
really need to support this basic
research to get at these fundamental
questions I'll just add that we are big
consumers of of the animal research and
we pay very close attention to what
kinds of time scales of learning we can
expect in different structures in the
brain understanding how in animal work
that people dissect the different kinds
of learning signals that you need to
drive different systems so you know it's
it's turtle scratch I mean we we read
turtle scratch because we want to
understand spinal networks so it's it's
not that we don't we aren't consumers of
those things and I agree that if you
don't do that kind of work I don't think
that you're going to advance any of the
types of work that I do for example
thank you for your talks today I'm from
very different backgrounds on my
background is mostly about biophysics of
the network I'm trying to put together
the group of socks that I heard today so
you know one thing was this common was
that the internal model across all these
talks and some talked about that how
like when they were evaluating an
internal model that trying to basically
see how something could compensate for
the errors that are basically created
but there's something that we said that
is the nervous system is always behind
the world right like it you can never
have too lag 0 at the beginning of your
experiments so how do you want to deal
with that situation because no matter
where you start and how you start you're
starting with a system that already is
making predictions or trying to
basically compensate for what for the
lack sign that that it goes through and
another girl and some others actually
through the later they said okay maybe
we have a breakdown of this black box of
internal model
and then we have basically a serial of
internal models building up on top of
each other and then then again another
concept constant in the mind that is
that if you have such thing then if an
error occurs in the system right then
how does the system tries to compensate
like if you have such sort of like
cereal categorization of these internal
models then how do you want it to
compensate for the real world or what's
happening the outside and that brings
basically i think that the connection to
the last series of talks is that i think
what's the last two talked mostly about
the higher functions and their everybody
talks about how you have like some
probabilistic model of your world and
maybe you know there's an overarching
principle here that you can go through
but there is something to be said that
is that it's not just the brain that can
act in this sort of manner right but you
have any physiological system let's say
your parasympathetic system is also
composed of excitable membrane it has
many common elements from biophysical
principle and it can compensate for the
perturbations that happen in the
external world so maybe maybe what we're
trying to do in crossing from basically
the biophysics to cognition is is
something that has to be gone through
basically this complex adaptive system
format of the network but this network
Oh as it gets bigger and bigger of
course it gets to do more complex things
but and then that that's how it reaches
the cognition perhaps I don't know
that's just like a very speculative like
100 years from now kind of speculation
but I think what's what's missing here
is that no one is talking about like how
a complex system replies to the external
altered alternating or altering let's
say environment from by a physics point
of view and I think that is something
that could be investigated and
eventually could link all these things
together
yeah well that's what that so but as I
said like I think there's a missed
connection from there to basically the a
general principle of how this systems
could react to a complex system in a
couple of system point of view that's
that's I think difference but of course
it's the basis of it with with this
question that I think reiterates the the
complexity of connecting two ends of
this line I want to thank again all the
speakers it was a fantastic day thank
you so much for coming and we will have
reception outside everybody can sort of
continue discussion afterwards thank you